Tasha is with us in Georgia starting off
this hour
hey Tasha how are you hi thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up alright so first off I'd
like to say I've had my I've had it
moment and so I've been an ostrich Aldi
here is about my money
and I'm taking financial peace now and
what I was getting everything together
to see how much I actually really owned
which is about forty four thousand half
of it is student loans which are current
and the other half about 22,000 is
everything else because I was normal and
it's pretty much all in collections and
Wow because like I said I've been an
actress oh I don't even know how much I
took while going through that and really
paying attention and you know getting
all that paperwork and everything
together I found out that one of the
companies tried to sue me two years ago
but I had moved to another state so I
guess that complicates things a little
bit so now I'm kind of wondering what
what do i tackle first do i tackle that
whole debt first because I'm afraid they
might try to come back and try to sue me
again or do i tackle my current debt
which is mostly my right and what's your
income forty-eight five good for you and
how much do you owe on your car
I owe nothing on my car I went and sold
my car and bought a who I'm serious so
yeah now so what are you on the other
twenty mm that's not student loans are
you paying anything currently at all on
any of them now no how long has it been
since you paid on any of it probably
like 2015 okay and what kinds of debt is
it mostly credit cards there are some
medical bills but most oh and then I had
a car repo'd in like 2014 and so one of
them is that it okay let's do two debts
snowballs is your student loan one
single loan or
a little owns it 3-1
okay let's debt snowball it okay and
work it off first you should be able to
do that in a little over a year on beans
and rice rice and beans okay once you're
clear on that then your next debt
snowball is on your defaulted debt and
the reason we're going to work it
differently is because you're not paying
anything on it so it doesn't free up
anything in your budget when you pay one
off right and there's no debt snowball
there's no snowball it just you know you
just blink in one off blinking one off
link and one off like that right so
here's what I'll do same thing will list
them smallest to largest
now old credit card debt that is five or
six years old we'll settle for somewhere
around 20 cents on the dollar of the
original debt okay so let's say you had
a thousand dollar debt and you call them
up and they go oh no it's three thousand
now because we've added all these fees
and interest because it's been all these
years and all this stuff you say well I
don't have that I do have five hundred
bucks
or I do have two hundred bucks or
whatever right and you've saved up a
little bit of money and you offer them
cash as settlement in full as a
percentage of the original debt okay
okay not as not as a percentage of what
they say is owed but a percentage of the
original debt some percentage of that
and that's what you'll be able to settle
it for now if there are tiny little
loans like two hundred bucks or
something like that
you just call up and get confirmation on
what they are and just pay up okay like
a little medical bill that was $70 and
they say yo 100 and 200 just pay it it's
not worth ruining because it's gonna
screw around with them for a week if you
don't so it's just go ahead and get it
but get it in writing from them
confirmation as to what you're gonna pay
as a settled amount or as I just the
right amount I mean they take it one
hundred two dollars okay send me an
email that that clears this debt in
writing and I will send that check to
you today okay cool
and this
that email you send that check out okay
or you you know you got this other one
that was a thousand they've jacked it up
to two thousand four hundred and twenty
two dollars but you settle it for three
hundred and three hundred bucks right
then you get that in writing before two
instructions you have to remember these
two instructions in writing before you
send them any money and you're settling
each one of these is a lump sum no
payments right okay save up save about
five hundred bucks and settle save up a
thousand bucks and settle save up five
hundred bucks and settle just like that
every time and so and what you're going
to find is that you may have to work on
these a month you have to mess with them
back and forth because you're dealing
with collectors and a lot of times
you're dealing with collectors from debt
buyers because the original doesn't even
hold the dead anymore right yeah and
you're gonna track them down and find
out who holds the debt but the two
instructions are it must be in writing
or you do not send them any money
because you can tell they're lying if
their mouths are moving do not give them
money unless you have it in writing and
keep a hardcopy print hit print don't
keep the email hit print on the email
staple a copy of the cashier's check or
the money order or whatever you sent to
that and keep it in a file for the next
ten years cuz this crap will come back
up god it has a high rate of
resurrection it comes back to life it's
zombie Ville okay now the second
instruction is do not allow them to have
electronic access to your checking
account because they will clean you out
some of them a high percentage of them
are crooks them being second dairy debt
buyer collectors there just crumbles
okay and so you have to get it in
writing and you cannot give them
electronic access to your checking
account because you agreed to three
hundred dollars and you look in there
and they took six hundred out and
there's not a lot you can do because you
own more than six hundred what are you
gonna do say you didn't keep your
agreement they're gonna say well you
didn't keep your agreement and then
you're getting this an arguing match so
do not let them take electronic access
so you can either wire
money you could do a prepaid debit card
with only the exact amount on it that's
the only kinds of stuff you can do all
right you know but you send them a check
if you want to but you cannot let them
have electronic permission to get into
your checking account and bounced around
so in writing no electronic access to
your checking account when you're
dealing with collectors it's okay to do
that when you're doing like your you
know your electric bill coming out or
something like that your cable bill mine
all comes directly out of my checking
account that's not a problem but I don't
let people that I'm adversarial with
that I'm in an argument with even if the
arguments settled have electronic access
to my account that's simple so that's
how you do it work the separate set that
snowball and what you're gonna probably
end up doing is saving up a little money
you have two or three isn't these in
play at any given time and you'll be
going whoever gives me the yes answer
first is gonna get this batch of money
and the other one will have to wait on
the next batch so you better say yes
quick and you learn to play them and
you're just gonna get you just got to
argue just get ready to argue and
they're not nice and you have to hang up
the phone when they're not nice and you
have to go through all this crap with
them but that's part of cleaning up your
mess glad you're not an ostrich anymore